Let's see. A couple of
announcements.
Tomorrow there will be quiz six
based on homework six just on the
crystallography.
There is a little bit at the end of
homework six on x-rays.
And we will just start to talk
about x-rays today,
so I think that we will leave that
out. It will just be based on
crystallography.
And I have asked the recitation
instructors to administer the test
at the end of the period so you can
have some chance to ask questions.
Last day we talked about
crystallography.
We were introduced to the seven
crystal systems and the 14 Bravais
lattices which are shown up on the
slide taken from the lecture notes.
And we saw that if we wanted to
describe the arrangement of atoms in
a crystal, we could do so by
combining the notion of the Bravais
lattice of which there are 14
distinct types with a basis.
The basis could be a single atom.
Could be a group of atoms. Could
be an ion pair.
Could be atom pair.
And we saw that got us through an
elaborate set of crystals.
And then towards the end we focused
on cubic crystals because cubic
crystals are representative of a
large number of metals in the
Periodic Table,
and it is much more tractable
mathematically.
We are going to focus on cubic
crystals, and I am going to continue
along with that today.
In particular, I want to start
looking at notation.
And the reason I want to look at
notation is I want to be able to
define a point,
a line and a plane so that when we
start characterizing crystals,
I can give you a mathematical
notation that represents the face of
the cube, the body diagonal of the
cube, a line going on the body
diagonal, a line going along the
edge. Instead of writing it in
words, I want to be able to do so
mathematically.
And so for that we are going to
turn to this handout which has the
elements of crystallographic
notation.
I want to quickly go through this.
I think last day we started talking
about position,
so I have drawn a little sketch here.
This is the unit cell.
The unit cell is the cube because
we are talking about a cubic system,
and this is just the lattice. I
have not put atoms here.
So I am just talking about lattice
points in space.
And, just to remind us,
a, b and c are the unit vectors,
and in a cubic system a equals b
equals c. And each of them is equal
to a, the lattice constant.
This is the lattice constant, a.
That's the dimension a,
the lattice constant. And all
angles are right angles,
so alpha equals beta equals gamma
equals 90 degrees.
Just to practice, the origin,
as I have shown here, all we do is
write zero, zero,
zero, as you would in your math
class. But don't put parentheses
around it because parentheses are
reserved for planes.
We are going to use parentheses
later on. Crystallographers have
their own notation.
So here is point a.
What do we see?
It is in the yz plane.
By the way, I have chosen a set of
coordinate axes that are in
conformity with the right-hand rule.
I don't care which axis you choose
to be x. It doesn't matter.
I generally like to make z vertical,
but I don't care,
as long as you use the right-hand
rule. You need to observe the
right-hand rule because in physics
you are going to find that there are
certain vector forces that
are the cross-product.
And, if you don't use the right-hand
rule convention,
you will get things identically
backwards. The thumb is your x-axis,
y-axis, z-axis,
however you want to do it.
I have the x-axis coming out of the
board, and the y-axis and the z-axis
are in the plane of the board.
If we come here, this point A is
zero units out on the x-axis,
it is one unit out on the y-axis and
one unit up on the z-axis,
so this will be zero, one, one.
And b, as I've drawn it,
looks like it is one unit out on the
x-axis, it is no units out on a
y-axis and a half a unit up on the
z-axis. That is one,
zero, one-half. That is about the
last time I am going to talk about
these things. It is more
interesting to talk about lines.
For lines, I am going to say let's
just follow along on the slide.
And the slide imitates what is
going on here.
Let's see. I've got a couple of
them I want to try.
Let's look at,
for starters, OB.
I want to look at OB.
I am going to start at the origin,
and I am going to come out to the
point B. And I have a vector on
this. It is emanating from the
origin out to B.
And what does it say to do?
It says define a vector from origin
to the point on a line,
choose the smallest set of integers
and no commas.
I put the origin,
which conveniently here is the
origin, out to the point
along that direction.
The vector OB,
as written, will go from there out
to one, zero, one-half.
But then it says no commas,
enclose in brackets and clear the
fractions. They don't like to have
fractions when you are talking about
lines, so clear the fractions and
multiply through,
then that will just double it,
two, zero, one. And you could say
what are they doing?
If you can imagine going out one
more unit cell,
this line would actually go through
the point two, zero, one.
You are just looking at the
projection along here.
You are just multiplying it.
And then it says no commas and
enclose in brackets.
This is called a bracket.
These staple-like things are called
brackets. That is the direction OB.
Let's see. What is the other one
we are going to do?
AO. It says you have to move the
origin to the base of the vector.
If I want to do AO,
I have to put the origin up here at
the tail of the vector.
If this is the origin, I am moving
actually what?
I am not moving anywhere in the
x-axis, but I am moving minus one in
the y-axis and minus one in the
z-axis in order to get this
direction. I am really going zero
in the x, I am going minus one in
the y and minus one in the z.
And you can see that since we don't
use commas, putting minus signs
would look cumbersome.
In crystallographic notation,
the minus sign is represented as a
macron. A macron is a line over.
This is zero, one bar, one bar.
That is equal to minus one.
Crystallographers use the term one
bar. This is 0,
one bar, one bar for this line A
down to origin.
That is how that is done.
Then it says we can denote an
entire family of directions
by carats.
Let's do that.
Suppose I wanted to say all of the
body diagonals.
Well, how would I get a body
diagonal? If this is the origin and
I want to go up the body diagonal,
it would be out one unit, out one
unit, out one unit.
So one, one, one, would be a body
diagonal. But suppose I want to say
all body diagonals?
That is one, one, one this
direction, one, one,
one that direction.
I want to get this body diagonal.
I want to get that body diagonal.
How do I do that? I can do that by
putting carats.
These are called carats.
Those of you who have done some
editing and proofreading know these
terms. This is all body diagonals.
We could do a few others while we
are at it. Suppose I wanted to do
all of the face diagonals like this,
like this, and then over here like
this, like this?
Well, what is a face diagonal?
Zero, one, one. All the face
diagonals. What about all cube
edges? What is a cube edge?
A cube edge could be this one: zero,
zero, one. This would
be all cube edges.
What does it mean?
It means write this out in full.
That is O, O, one; O, O, one bar; O,
one, O. I am using O for zero.
I am cluing you into
crystallographers' talk.
That is how they talk. O and one
bar. You are going to be really hip
if you end up in an elevator with a
bunch of crystallographers.
And there are two others here.
One, O, O, and one bar, O, O.
Well, how many faces are there?
Six. How many face edges? Six.
And, look, just going through the
permutations and combinations gives
you exactly the number that you
should have. This is mathematics
imitating reality.
That is good. And likewise here.
If you go through all the
permutations, combinations of zero,
one and one bar, you will end up
with all of the possibilities for
face diagonals,
all the possibilities for body
diagonals.
I think I have a cartoon here that
shows all of the different diagonals
that are possible when you mix one
and one bar. That is good.
So far so good. That is pretty
simple. Now let's look at planes.
For planes we use something called
the Miller indices for describing
planes. And they are named after
the British mineralogist William
Hallowes Miller who,
back in the 1830s, gave us this
means of describing a plane.
And I think, rather than writing it
down, we will just follow along here
because you have the notes in front
of you. You know from your math
that the equation of a plane is x
over a plus y over b plus z over c
equals one, **x/a + y/b + z/c = 1**
and a, b and c are the intercepts
with the x, y and z axes
respectively. What Miller did is he
said let's let h be one over a,
k be one over b and l equals one
over c.
So this becomes the equation of the
plane, hx plus ky plus lz equals one.
**hx + ky + lz = 1** And now what
you do is take the h,
k and l and enclose those in
parentheses. In other words,
he is taking the plane index to be
the reciprocals of the intercepts
with the three axes.
And you will see why in a second.
Why do it that way?
Because every once in a while
something like this happens.
Here is a simple one just to get
our feet wet. Here a,
b and c are the unit vectors,
so this is the x-axis in the same
convention I have chosen.
X is coming out of the plane of the
slide, y is moving to the right and
z is moving up.
Here is a plane that is shaded in.
And what do you see? It cuts the
x-axis at x equals plus one-half,
it cuts the y-axis at y equals plus
one, and it never cuts the z-axis.
It is parallel to the z-axis.
Mathematically,
we would say the z-intercept is
infinity. And who wants to have
infinity? Now you see the wisdom of
Miller. Miller said let's describe
this in terms of the reciprocals.
What is the reciprocal of one-half?
It is two. What is the reciprocal
of one? It is one.
And what is the reciprocal of
infinity? Zero.
We can describe this plane as the
two, one, zero plane.
Whenever you see a zero,
whatever place the zero lies that
means that plane is parallel to that
axis, so right away I can say that
is a plane that is parallel to the
z-axis. It does not cross the
z-axis. So there it is.
There is the formula. You take the
reciprocal of the intercepts,
put them side-by-side, no commas,
and this is why we save the
parentheses. That is why we don't
put our position in parentheses
because we are saving parentheses
for the plane.
Let's do a few more.
This is a lot of fun on a Monday.
See, you are excited to be back in
class. There is a cool thing that
happens when you use Miller indices.
You see what I just did? I just
drew a direction,
and that direction is the two,
one, O direction. And what do you
notice about the position of two,
one, O versus the two, one, O plane?
When you write directions,
according to this formula and planes
according to Miller indices,
the two, one, O direction is
perpendicular to the
two, one, O plane.
Two, one, O direction is
perpendicular to the two,
one, O plane. Let's do another one.
This is a good one. This is a
plane that cuts the y-axis at y
equals one. It is parallel to the
x-axis and parallel to the z-axis.
It never cuts the x or the z-axes,
so that is an O, one, O plane. I
mean, you can do that in your head.
That is an O, one, O plane, that is
an O, one, O plane and so on and so
forth. Here is an O,
two, O plane. Why?
Well, because it cuts the y-axis at
y equals one-half,
you take the reciprocal,
which is two, so O, two, O.
And let's try again. Well,
there is O, one, O direction.
And what do you know? The O,
one, O direction is normal to the O,
one, O plane and O, two, O direction
is normal to the O,
two, O plane. What do you know
about the O, one,
O direction and the O,
two, O direction? They are the same
direction. O anything O is going to
be along the y-axis.
Now, that is an O,
two, O plane. I could shift the
origin to here,
couldn't I? Then that would be an O,
two, O plane and that would be an O,
two, O plane. Oh, here is some more.
One, one, one.
Well, look at this plane here.
It cuts the x-axis at x equals one,
the y-axis at y equals one, the
z-axis at z equals one.
Shade that in.
That is the one,
one, one plane, but that is also a
one, one, one plane.
We can keep shifting the origin.
I don't know where the origin of
the universe is,
so I can move this anywhere along.
Here is one. Here is backwards.
See, this now is one,
one, one bar, because if I put the
origin here I am cutting the x-axis
at plus one, I am cutting the y-axis
at plus one, but I have a negative
tilt to this plane so the z-axis is
being cut at minus one.
Again, we try to avoid the minus
sign.
And, instead, we put the macron over
the number. In that way we give the
minus indication on a number,
no commas in parentheses. Now,
let's do the test. Here is the one,
one, one direction. And, sure
enough, the one,
one, one direction cuts the one,
one, one plane normally. Let's try
over here. There is the one,
one, one bar direction. It cuts
through the one,
one, one bar plane normally.
Fantastic.
And we can do families of planes as
well. Let's look at families of
planes. What kind of families could
we come up with if we want to do
families of planes with brace
brackets? Families of planes use
braces. If I want to say all cubed
faces that would be O, O, one.
Because O, one,
O we saw cuts the y-axis parallel to
the x-z plane.
That is going to tell you to roll
over zero, zero,
one and one bar in this manner.
Only instead of brackets you have
braces. How many faces on a cube?
There are six. How many
combinations of zero,
one and one bar are there?
Six. There you go. By the way,
one other thing.
If you want to be hip with the
crystallographers,
this is one way of writing it.
Another way of writing it is one,
O, O, which is equivalent to O, O,
one. But crystallographers like to
put things in ascending order.
A crystallographer would never
write one, O, O.
A crystallographer would write O,
O, one. That is a cool factor there.
You never know when you are going
to meet a crystallographer on an
elevator. It could be the
icebreaker because
they might be shy.
Now, the last thing I want to do is
talk about the distance calculation,
another virtue of using Miller
indices. I want to put this up here
because it is on the handout,
but I want to make sure that it gets
on the board. The hkl plane is
perpendicular to the hkl direction
when we use such a notation.
And then I want to go back to the
previous slide.
Go back two of them because it is
easier to see here.
I want to calculate the distance
between adjacent planes of the same
index. We can calculate the
distance between adjacent planes of
the same index.
What is the distance between two
adjacent planes of some value hkl?
That is given by the following
formula, which again is a testimony
to Miller. The distance,
and I am going to subscript it hkl
because they are all the same index,
is given by a, which is the lattice
constant, divided by the square root
of h squared plus k squared plus l
squared where a is the
lattice constant.
Let's test it.
If hkl is O, one,
O, trivially that separation should
be a, the lattice constant.
And I think you can see that quite
nicely up on the screen here.
It is one lattice constant between
successive O, one,
O planes. Let's try it with O,
two, O. It is going to be the
square root of two squared which is
a over two. And,
sure enough, what is the distance
between O, two,
O and the adjacent plane comparable
to it?
It is only half a lattice constant.
In essence, if you look here, every
O, two, O plane is only half a
lattice constant away.
Every O, one, O plane is full
lattice constant.
What you are really seeing then is
that the d goes down,
the distance between planes goes
down as the Miller index goes up.
What is the lowest Miller index?
The lowest Miller index is O,
O, one. That is a lattice constant.
That is the maximum separation.
And I think you can see that as you
move hkl to higher values,
what you are doing is you are
cutting at a higher angular slice.
And, as you cut for a higher
angular slice,
the distance between successive
planes is going to be reduced.
Mathematically what is going on,
this is getting larger in the
denominator, this is remaining the
same, so that distance becomes
closer and closer together.
And why am I showing you this?
Because we are going to use it in
the very next unit.
Not three years from now.
We are going to use it in the next
unit when we take this information
and characterize crystals.
And we are going to characterize
atomic structure by the use of
something that is comparable in
dimension. If we are going to
measure the dimension of the human
hair, we are not going to use a
yardstick. What kind of numbers are
we looking at for these distances?
We are looking at something down
around some number of angstroms.
We better find some tool that gives
me units of some number of angstroms.
And that tool will be x-rays.
Now let's look at characterization
of atomic structure by x-rays.
Today I want to talk about the
discovery of x-rays and the
underlying physics.
And then next day we are going to
look at application.
First of all, what are x-rays?
X-rays are a form of
electromagnetic radiation.
What does that mean?
That means all of these formulas
apply. E equals h nu equals hc over
lambda equals hc nu bar.
That applies. And the special
characteristic of x-rays is lambda
is very short and typically there is
no hard rule on this,
but just in round numbers we are
looking at between one one-hundredth
to one hundred angstroms.
It is centered at about one
angstrom where one angstrom is equal
to ten to the minus ten meters.
I know it is not an SI unit,
and you know my aversion to the
nanometer, but I will put it up here
because I am required by the
International Union of Pure and
Applied Chemistry on the Systeme
International to put this
contemptible unit here,
but I love the angstroms.
This is just my personal preference.
Let's plug in a value.
Suppose we have one angstrom as the
wavelength if I use hc over lambda
where lambda equals one angstrom,
or ten to the minus ten meters. I
end up with 12,
00 electron volts per photon.
And this is clearly going to be
powerful radiation.
Let's take a look here.
I pulled this out of the back of
the text. This has ionization
energies for the first
seven elements.
If you look here,
in green I am showing the first
ionization energy.
And this is right off your Periodic
Table. 13.6 electron volts.
I have rounded it to two
significant figures.
It is 13.6 for hydrogen,
it is 25.0 for helium, it is 5 for
lithium and so on.
These are tiny, tiny numbers.
These are electron volts. Now what
we can do is look down this row.
This is the last electron to come
off. The second ionization energy
of helium is for a one electron atom.
Helium has two electrons.
If it loses one, it only has one
left, so this is a one electron atom,
this is a one electron atom and this
is a one electron atom.
And look at the energies.
This is for the inner most electron.
One electron atom,
that will conform to the Bohr model.
And, sure enough, look at the
ratios of these numbers.
These are determined by x-ray
photoelectron spectroscopy.
And roughly 14 times four is 56,
so there it is. One to four to nine
to 16. And it is just a
manifestation of what you have seen
as the ground state energy in the
Bohr model goes as the square of the
atomic number.
Everything is making sense,
but what I draw your attention to is,
look, this is the innermost held
electron of nitrogen.
It is 668 electron volts and I have
12,400. This has enormous power.
This has the power to ionize inner
shell electrons.
This is like a bowling alley.
All the pins are going flying here.
This is incredible energy. What
are the underlying principles here?
Well, I think we have to start with
a history lesson.
We will go back to November 8,
1895.
It was a dark and stormy night,
really. It was a dark and stormy
night on November 8,
1895 in WŸrzburg, Bavaria,
which is now part of Germany.
There was a physics professor there
by the name of Wilhelm Roentgen.
And he was doing research,
as many people were at that time,
on gas discharge tubes. We have
seen gas discharge tubes a number of
times in 3.091,
and Roentgen was part of that army
of researchers.
And what Roentgen's specialty was,
he was pursuing gas discharge
spectral analysis under reduced
pressure. He was pumping down with
a vacuum pump to get the gas
pressure very,
very low, and very,
very high voltage.
That is what his take was.
He wanted to look at high voltage
and very, very low pressure.
And let's take a look at what his
apparatus looked like.
Well, we will start with the tube.
As you have seen many times, we
will put the cathode to the left and
we will put the anode to the right.
And he had the laboratory on the
second floor.
His apartment was on the first floor.
And down in the basement he had a
bunch of batteries.
Chromic acid in open beakers down
in the basement.
Let's indicate that with the
classical symbol.
And this altogether put out about
20 volts. And he was a professor of
physics who understood some
electrical engineering. He
had a choke coil here.
The choke coil would take the
current, store up,
and eight times a second it would
discharge. And it would discharge
at 35,000 volts.
He could take 20 volts and up it to
35,000 by the use of this choke coil.
Eight times a second he had 35,
00 volts coming off the cathode here.
You have bam, bam, bam.
But speed that up about eight times.
That is what is going on. And so
with 35,000 volts he launches
electrons off the cathode,
and they go zooming across what is
very, very low pressure gas and
crash into the anode.
In the meantime, to keep this thing
dynamically at low pressure,
this goes to a vacuum pump to keep
this thing pumped down as low as he
can. And he was measuring what was
going on inside this gas tube.
And so he had a detector.
His detector was over here off to
the side. The detector consisted of
either a piece of cloth or a paper
towel which had been painted with a
chemical that would glow when it was
struck by something.
What would the something be?
The something would be electrons or
photons that have an energy high
enough to cause excitation of
something in the paint and then
reemission in the visible.
It doesn't do any good to excite
electrons in the detector to have
them reemit outside the visible.
That is what is going on. This was
paper or cloth,
and it was painted with an aqueous
solution of barium plantinocyanide
which glows green when
it is excited.
And this is called a scintillation
screen. It comes from the Latin
word for spark.
Scintilla means spark in Latin.
When the screen is struck by some
form of energy it will glow.
And so he had dinner. He was up on
the second floor cranking away after
dinner. It was dark and raining.
He had the windows open.
And a streetlight was coming in.
Oh, by the way, Roentgen suffered
from Daltonism.
He was red-green colored blind.
And this was a green screen. And
with 35,000 volts,
even at reduced pressure,
given the capacity of those days for
vacuum pumps, he still had a lot of
glow from the tube.
The tube is glowing,
he has a streetlight in the
background, so he decides to close
the drapes and take out
the streetlight.
And then, furthermore,
he decides to darken the room so he
puts a cardboard box over the tube.
Now the tube is enclosed in a
cardboard box so it is not glowing
visibly to him.
It is glowing inside the box.
And he continues to see
scintillation,
continues to see things glowing.
He says that is something
interesting. The other thing that
happened which was kind of
interesting, his graduate student
who had prepared some
of the apparatus --
I guess he was practicing painting
the scintillation screen.
What the student had done was to
paint the letter A on a paper towel,
and he left the paper towel on the
lab bench. Now,
Röntgen has the tube enclosed in
cardboard, this thing is glowing and
he looks down and sees the letter A
and the letter A is glowing.
He is going, wait a minute, this is
crazy.
He takes a piece of black paper and
puts it here in between the tube and
the screen, and the screen continues
to glow. He had a deck of playing
cards in his lab.
Don't laugh. That is how Mendeleev
discovered periodicity.
He takes a playing card and puts it
in front and the tube continues to
glow. And then he takes a book and
puts it in between and the tube
continues to glow.
He is going wait a minute.
Then he grabs a piece of lead foil.
He puts the lead foil in here.
And what happens is that where the
lead foil is the screen is not
glowing, but then he sees the
outline of the bones of his hand on
the lead holding the lead foil.
All of this stuff is going on, and
he just goes to town.
He says, you know what,
this cannot be electrons because
electrons cannot live in air.
They will be stopped by air.
And he knew about radio waves from
Hertz and said could this be some
form of mysterious radiation that is
capable, and he was really afraid to
say this, of penetrating matter?
It is 1895. Are you going to come
out publicly and say I have a form
of radiation that can penetrate
matter? He gets a magnet out.
He moves a magnet and it doesn't
change, so this stuff is not
sensitive to magnetic field.
But, if he puts a magnet here,
of course he gets changes.
He cannot see this stuff.
He can only see evidence of it.
It is mysterious. He calls it x,
the unknown quantity. It is x
radiation. This is November 8,
1895. And, to show you what a great
scientist he was,
rather than rushing to publication,
he spends all of November and
December repeating the experiment
and trying it in different ways
until he is convinced that
the effect is real.
And then around Christmas time of
1895 he sends off a manuscript.
And it is published in the first
week of January of 1896 and takes
the world by storm.
He is announcing that there is a
form of radiation that can penetrate
matter. And, furthermore,
he has an x-ray of a human hand.
This is the 1890s and people are
very prude, very private,
and he has a form of radiation that
can look inside the human body.
This is really shocking stuff.
Already on January 16, 1896 there
is an article in The New York Times
about this stuff,
a mysterious form of radiation.
By the way, when he was doing these
experiments how was he recording his
results? He was recording his
results on photographic film,
and his photographic film was
fogging.
He had his photographic film stored
in a cabinet on the other side of
the lab, and half of the time he
would take the photographic film out
and it was fogged.
He said whatever this stuff is,
it is penetrating everything. It is
penetrating the doors of his file
cabinet. They weren't steel cased.
They were probably wooden file
cabinets. So,
widespread adoption,
some of it silly. What are some of
the silly ones?
In London there was a manufacturer
who announced,
remember this is prudish Victorian
England, that he could sell you
x-ray proof ladies underwear.
In France, there was no such thing.
The French don't care about such
matters. Remember,
the French Daguerre had invented
halide photography.
So someone in France offered to
x-ray the human soul.
This is very good. I am ashamed to
say what happened in
the United States.
The New York City College of
Physicians and Surgeons announced
that they would use x-rays to
project anatomical diagrams from
textbooks onto the brains of medical
students, thereby creating,
and I quote, an enduring impression.
In Iowa, somebody offered to x-ray
copper pennies and thereby turn them
into gold. That is what happened.
But, seriously,
what really did happen very quickly
was the use of x-rays as a
diagnostic tool.
Already in February of 1896 there
was a Scottish physician who used
x-rays. It is simple.
You could do this in a high school.
I mean what is it? It is just a
gas discharge tube,
a pair of electrodes with a feed
through, and he has 35,
00 volts, I mean that is the kind of
stuff that comes off the chassis of
your television set.
This is trivial stuff.
People were putting these things
everywhere.
They were sitting in offices in open
view. Nobody knew.
This physician had a seamstress
come to him. She was involved in an
industrial accident in a mill.
A needle broke off in her hand.
Now, how would you find the needle
in a hand? You cannot.
X-ray, they identified the location
of the needle,
performed the surgery and boom.
For dental applications it was
immediately adopted.
They were already using it in 1899
as a form of treatment for cancer.
Very interesting.
It took over. What is the relative
physics? What is going on here?
Where do we have to go? I say we
have to look at the anode because
that is where the electrons are
crashing into.
That is the site of the collision.
Something is happening at that
anode. Let's look inside the anode.
Suppose it is copper, what could we
say about it? This is where the
electron collision is.
That is the maximum impact.
Let's just see what might be going
on. I want to show you the power of
estimation. I have shown you that
with nitrogen it is 668 electron
volts to get to the inner shell
electrons. What about in the case
of the anode? What is going on
there? Well, I can say what is the
energy of the 1s electron in copper
28 plus? That is a one
electron system.
And you know that in real copper
with all of its electrons this value
is going to be an over-estimate
because the presence of all the
other electrons is going to sap some
of the protonic Coulombic force.
This will be an upper bound of what
that energy could be.
And we know that is simply equal to
the energy of the 1s in hydrogen
times z squared.
If I take 13.6 electron volts times
29 squared, I get 11.
thousand electron volts,
which is still less than the 35
thousand electron volts that
Roentgen had. Roentgen is running a
huge bowling alley here.
He is able to knock out 1s
electrons from copper.
And what happens when you knock out
inner shell electrons?
What is the next thing that happens?
Let's look at an energy
level diagram.
Let's suppose that this is the anode.
This is the anode in the gas tube.
This is an energy level diagram.
This is going to be n equals
infinity. And we will just do a few
of them. This is n equals four,
n equals three, n equals two and n
equals one. Not to scale.
I am trying to show that they are a
little bit farther apart as you go
lower and lower.
And so this is ground state energy
E1, this is n equals two shell,
n equals three shell, n equals four
shell.
And out here it is zero.
And so what do I have? I have some
incident electron that comes zooming
in here. This is incident.
This is the one that has been
accelerated. The energy of this
electron is all kinetic.
And that is equal to product of the
charge on the electron which is
elemental e times a plate voltage
which is 35 thousand volts.
That is how I get 35 thousand
electron volts as the energy.
And we have just shown that it has
enough energy that it can even knock
out an inner shell electron.
It can even dislodge an inner shell
electron. Let's see what would
happen if that were the case.
It dislodges an inner shell
electron. What is the next thing?
I have a vacancy down here. What
will happen? One electron will fall
from n equals two to n equals one.
And when it does so it gives off
radiation.
Well, if it falls from n equals two
to n equals one,
there is a slim chance it might even
fall from n equals three to n equals
one or maybe even n equals four to n
equals one. Well,
heck, if it can go from two to one,
there is a vacancy in two. I might
get three to two,
I might get four to two,
and you get the picture. You get a
whole cascade here.
Each one of these gives off photons,
photon emission.
You have expulsion of k shell all of
the electrons,
but you can go all the way down to
the k shell electrons and then
cascade and accompanied by
photoemission.
The difference is that instead of
being in the visible or the infrared,
these energy levels are so,
so tightly bound that this is in the
x region of the spectrum.
And we have labels for these
different photons.
And, first of all,
the spectroscopists don't like the
numbers. This is the chemist
notation, n equals one,
n equals two, n equals three,
n equals four. The spectroscopists
call the ground state k shell,
this is m shell, this is n shell.
I left out a letter in the alphabet.
K, l shell, m shell, n shell. We
can label this as a photon that came
from a cascade down to the k shell.
And to distinguish this k shell
electron from the k shell electron
involving a transition from n equals
three down to n equals one,
we have a second indicator.
And that is the subscript alpha.
This means the cascade down to k
shell and the alpha represents how
far the electron traveled from one
shell away. That means from n
equals two to n equals one,
this is a k beta photon, this is a k
gamma photon.
This is like a Lyman series.
This is like a Balmer series
because it always ends at n equals
two. N equals three to n equals two
gives us a photon,
and that photon is going to be
called L alpha.
N equals four to n equals two will
give us a photon,
and that is going to be called L
beta. I am going to get
a whole spectrum.
Let's take a look at what that
spectrum might look like.
I could calculate any one of these.
I could say lambda of copper k
alpha would equal what?
It is the same as you have seen
before, hc over what?
The energy of n equals two shell to
energy of n equals one shell.
**lambda Cu K alpha = hc/(E2-E1)
What can we do? We
can measure this.
We know h and c.
We can calculate what those energy
levels are. Let's plot this out.
I could make a plot of wavelength
intensity and I will get an entire
spectrum of lines.
This is high wavelength so that
means energy is increasing from
right to left.
The highest energy is over here.
What's the highest energy up there?
The highest energy looks like n
equals four down to n equals one.
And that is going to be over here.
This could be k gamma, then k beta,
k alpha. And then the L lines are
three to two, four to two,
so they are over here. This is L
alpha, L beta and so on.
And these different wavelengths are
associated with different energies.
And these different energies are
associated with what?
They are associated with the binding
inside the atom,
inside the target.
Every target has its own number of
protons, its own number of electrons,
so this set of lines is
characteristic of the target.
And I had to do a whole year of
x-ray crystallography as a junior
back at the University of Toronto.
We used copper as the target.
And I will know on my deathbed that
the wavelength of copper k alpha is
1.5418 angstroms.
If I walk into the room and see 1.
418 angstroms, that is copper. It
comes from copper.
And any other element is going to
give me a different set of lines.
What I am learning here is I have a
way of identifying elements.
This is now turning into something
that could be a technique
of chemical analysis.
And we will return next day to see
what else we can do with it.
For the last five minutes, I am
going to show you a little bit more
about Roentgen and his discovery.
But I wanted to just draw attention
to our winner from Friday who was
unable to attend the lecture.
And so I want to ask Nivair Gabriel
to stand and accept her
acknowledgment for the fine job she
did on the Actinides thing.
And she is wearing her scarf.
Why don't you come down and people
can see you wearing the really super
hot American Chemical Society
scarf. [APPLAUSE]
Now, here is the dark and stormy
night the following morning.
It is sunny.
This is Roentgen's laboratory on the
second floor of his flat in WŸrzburg.
It is a museum today.
And you can see the tubes and the
lead wires going down to the
basement and so on.
Hold it. I don't want a lot of
noise. This is the first radiograph
ever. This is Roentgen's wife
Bertha. He noticed that there was a
shadow with the lead.
Roentgen was smart.
He had to share the glory so he
said, honey, would you mind coming
upstairs, I would like to take your
picture. And so Bertha put her hand
in the path of the x-ray,
and for 15 full minutes waited while
those x-rays went through.
You can see the ring on her finger
and so on. She endured in that 15
minutes greater than a lifetime dose
of what we would consider safe today.
People just did not know. Anyway.
This gave birth to medical
radiography. And I would,
just out of curiosity, like to know
if there is anybody in this room who
has never had a medical or dental
x-ray. I see very few.
I see a few hands. To you I say
congratulations and I hope you keep
up the good work.
Here is the second thing.
We have radiography that came out
of Roentgen's discovery.
Roentgen had a torsion balance.
Like the Justice,
she has the two scales.
On one scale you put the unknown
and the other scale you put the
calibrated mass.
He had a set of brass weights here
in a wooden box,
and he closed the wooden box and
irradiated the box with the x-rays
and took this photograph.
And what do you see? You see that
different materials have different
electron densities and,
therefore, the wood is transparent,
more or less, to x-rays.
Whereas, the brass is less so.
You have a differentiation. The
way we see things is by
differentiation.
Here you have a differentiation.
He could identify what was in the
box when the box was closed.
That gives rise to security
technology. Every time you go to
the airport you are subjected to
this, and it started with Roentgen.
Roentgen also had a gun.
It was a musket. He wasn't holding
up convenience stores.
What are you laughing at?
He had a gun. He went hunting.
He took an x-radiograph of his gun.
And this is used today. It gives
birth to the technology of failure
analysis. In fact,
there are certain types of weld,
typically involving very dangerous
circumstances such as pressure
vessels that are going to contain
steam at very, very high pressures.
The code is that every inch of the
welded seam must be inspected by
x-radiation in order to find what?
Internal cracks. Because, if there
is a crack, there is a difference in
electron density.
And so you will see contrast in the
x-ray photograph.
From that experiment come three
technologies.
And for his work,
Roentgen was the recipient of the
very first Nobel prize in physics.
It was awarded in 1901. He was the
unanimous choice of the world
physics community for what he had
done. And you are going to see next
day more that the discovery of
x-rays enabled.
But one last thing,
what a fine human being he was.
You know what he did with his
winnings?
He donated them to the University of
WŸrzburg to be made an endowment for
student scholarships.
And, to this day, physics students
at the University of WŸrzburg are
recipients of scholarships that were
endowed by Roentgen with his Nobel
prize winnings in 1901.
I will see you on Wednesday.